you're also going to be in pan aren't
you tell me about that just start
addressing on that and it started
filming my I don't start filming till
June
but the rehearsals that we've done Hugh
Jackman is amazing to work with Garrett
Hedlund is also one of those actors that
is just scoot in this cookie this
character is gonna be really intense and
Hugh Jackman's guarantors deliciously
evil one of those characters he's placed
black beard and he's gonna be one of
those characters but you're going to
love to hate Rooney Mara as Tiger Lily
is beautiful and elegant and also just a
strength to her as well she's an amazing
actress and I think she's gonna do tight
Lily
great justice it's shaping up to be a
great movie and Joe Wright is someone
I've owned for a while and he is
meticulous he down to every detail to
the button on your jacket to the way a
curl in your hair is he he he oversees
every every single facet of the
operation and I think that is something
that is going to make the film great he
knows exactly how it wants everything to
look and he oversees everything tell us
a little bit about your role in the film
and who you gonna be working with well
Blackbeard is played by Hugh Jackman I
play his first mate who is Bishop Bishop
is kind of a warrior pirate who's quite
a scary individual I think he's somebody
you can trust if he's on your goods
you're on his good side but if you're on
his bad side you don't want him near you
and he's definitely someone who is
pivotal to the story as it moves on he's
a very religious person
it doesn't like taking life but he will
if necessary and what kind of work on
the background to be done for pan the
pan I didn't I kind of approach a lot of
my characters in the same way I build
the same thing is when you're doing a
fantasy you have to build a
imaginary places they come from so but
with Bishop he's definitely African so I
kind of built him on a Ghanaian Nigerian
type background so he comes from that
kind of region of West Africa Senegal
you know a kind of area and so I brought
that to it and also brought a lot of the
fantasy ideals and kind of mesh them
together to make this character I'm
still in the process of it because we're
kind of we're still in the restaurant
process but the the costume the makeup
the hair everything that is going into
the character is really helping me so
it's good fun
you